نحن نتابع مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه التغطيه
الان ل همم نتفاعل او نغطي عفوا هذه
الاحداث الاميه تشهدها
همم اقليم خيبر بتحديث مدينه بيشاور التي
شاهدت انفجارا همم هذا همم قبل همم قليل
بعد صلاه الظهر في احد المساجد الواقعه
قرب همم احد همم المقرات الامنيه وقد قتل
في هذا الانفجار او في هذه العمليه
الامنيه كما نقلت وكاله رويترز اكثر من 19
قتيلا وعشرات الجرحى جرى طبعا هذا
الانفجار نعود الى عبد الرحمن المطر
يفيدنا ربما بالمزيد من المعطيات
المعلومات هل من جديد عبد الرحمن
حتى الان عبد الصمد ما تزال المعلومات
تتوافر من مدينه بيشاور بعد وقوع هذا
انفجار حالا من الاستنفار الشديد في
المستشفيات الحكوميه في بشاور وتحديدا في
المستشفى الرئيسي المعروف باسم ليدي
ليدينج هوسبيتل لا هو المستشفى الحكومي
الرئيسي في مدينه بيشاور الذي حتى الان
يستقبل عشرات من المصابين بهذا التفجير
بالفعل هناك ضحايا علمنا ايضا انا بين
الضحايا عدد من رجال الشرطه الذين كانوا
يؤدون صلاه الظهر في هذا المستشفى في هذا
المسجد الذي وقع في التفجير بمحاذات المقر
الرئيسي ل همم الشرطه في مدينه بيشاور ومن
حيث بالمناسبه يتم التحكم بكل تحركات
الشرطه وكل توزيعهم وكل المهامه التي همم
يتم تكاليفهم بها من هذا المقال تحديدا من
المسجد الملاصق لهذا المقر همم وقع هذا
التفجير حتى الان لا توجد معلومات مؤكده
عن طبيعه هذا المعلومات تتضارب بينما اذا
كان هناك شخص انتحاري تمكن من دخول المسجد
وتفجير نفسه او ان هناك عبوه ناسفه تم
وضعها داخل المسجد لكن بالتاكيد الانفجار
كان كبير الاثار كانت واضحه في الصور التي
همم شاهدناها والتي نقلت على الاقل
اللحظات الاولى من لهذا التفجير عشرات من
الجرحى هناك شبه انهيار لاحد الجوانب او
احد همم الجدران في هذا المسجد تضرر كبير
من الداخل شهود العيان يؤكد بان حقيقه ان
هناك حاله من الارباك الشديد ما تزال
موجوده في المنطقه الاسيما مع محاوله نقل
هؤلاء المصابين ومحاوله التعامل مع الموقف
لا سيما وان هناك بالتاكيد حاله من
الارباح الشديد بمجرد وقوع مثل هكذا
انفجارات مع وجود اكثر من جهه امنيه
ومحاوله اكثر من جهه امنيه للوصول ومحاوله
ربما التعامل او التعاطي مع
هذا الموقف لابد ايضا من ذكر بان الحكومه
المحليه في اقليم خيبر حاليا هي حقوق هي
حكومه انتقاليه وليست الحكومه المنتخبه
التي قدم اعضائها استقالتهم قبل نحو
اسبوعين من الان ضمن نوع من انواع الضغوط
السياسيه التي كان يمارسونها على الحكومه
المركزيه الحاليا هي حكومه انتقاليه حكومه
تصريف اعمال وبالتالي ربما لا يمكن اتخاذ
الكثير من الخطوات او القرارات السياسيه
المتعلقه بتامين الموقف الامني الحديث هنا
في باكستان عاده ما يدور عن ان لا يوجد
غطاء سياسي للوضع الامني المطرب او حتى
للوضع الاقتصادي الذي كان يتحدث اليه
ضيفكم من اسلام باشا قبل قليل الوضع
الاقتصادي المطرب الوضع الامني اذا المطرب
هو انعكاس مباشر للوضع السياسي غير
المستقر هنا في الباكستان وبالتاكيد هناك
دائما دعوات لان يكون الوضع السياسي او
لان يشكل الوضع السياسي غطاءا
للحاله الامنيه والاقتصاديه هنا في
الباكستان طيب